sometimes referred to as the Great Wall
of Dorset
three miles long it's just one symbol of
the seemingly endless wealth of this
area's largest private landowner
conservative MP Richard Drax this is
charbra Park Richard drax's enormous
country estate thousands of acres worth
but it's not just what's behind me that
belongs to him and his family they own
huge swathes of Dorset and get most of
their income today from farming and from
rent but the origins of this vast wealth
are four thousand miles away the sugar
plantations of Barbados
built in the 1600s Drax Hall overlooks
land where a fortune was built on the
back of the slave trade
passed through the family for
Generations Richard Drax is the latest
to inherit now there are calls for him
to relinquish it we are seeking
compensation Mr Drax visited us
and was engaged in conversation with the
prime minister
and myself reappealing to his conscience
and if that does not work they will have
to go to the ultimate which is the word
Court in order to resolve these issues
back in South Dorset Grafton Striker a
constituent of Richard Drax of Barbadian
Heritage agrees I was born in Barbados I
see the crops I saw black people cutting
sugarcane and Barbados and it broke my
heart I think the symbol of the wealth
Has Come From Slavery the slave trade
of the Caribbean and of Barbados and we
were looking to handle them back Richard
Drax he's been an MP since 2010 but has
never spoken publicly about his family's
historic links to slavery time's up Mr
Drax he was confronted by it though in
the wake of the black lives matter
movement as anti-racism campaigners
called on him to make amends but should
he bear any responsibility for the
actions of his ancestors the reparations
argument has become very controversial
because people look at it as a money
grab they think it's a long time ago but
the river reverberations rather of it is
still being felt by the descendants of
enslaved people
as a newly established Republic Barbados
is looking to its future but also its
past with talks ongoing between the
country's politicians and Richard Drax
he refused to comment but as the calls
grow louder can they break through the
silence in South Dorset and behind the
wall is anyone willing to listen Liz
Bates Sky News Dorset